[Music]
welcome back to careful boys we are very
careful today we have a very exciting
episode because we are going to be uh
taking a big old [ __ ]
on the brand of my man anthony league
i realize what the real meaning of
careful boys is it's not really careful
getting cancelled we have to be careful
with each other yeah we say something
like i'm being a good dad or something i
get [ __ ] [ __ ] out for not going to
the best boxing match in the world he's
gonna [ __ ] have his nude it's not his
noodles are already in costco and i'm
sure we're going to take it down a hole
somewhere
do you want to be proud for yourself so
you get smashed on dude
i feel like i've been getting smashed on
the last few days for sure so just bring
all the heat i don't know it's a disc or
a compliment anymore in here it's just
like
whatever makes you uncomfortable is what
it's supposed to be
whatever you're proud of you sex have
her oh [ __ ] my bad you are a sex driver
you're such a sex-having individual yeah
and then when the cameras are off you
dick sucker like oh man oh
that's still sexy
it's called oral sex
it was talking about you too we was both
dick suckers over here i don't care i'm
not
a sex table over there but yeah tell us
about your noodles being in costco
that's a [ __ ] big
costco dude oh man can you get in a can
you give them like a good word for me
like i'm trying to get mushrooms oh just
get joe in there
he's like uh you could just get a
membership
[Laughter]
so so um
i uh personally obviously am not the
salesperson talking to all the
distribution channels and stuff like
that but i will say well i'm talking to
the wrong person then
[Laughter]
conversation over but i will say you're
useless to me
[Laughter]
it hasn't been dope costco was like on
our kind of like our top list of like
trying to get into it's one of those um
especially in like distribution in
america too
uh costco's credibility to be able to
get into is really really high yeah it's
high risk because uh it's not high
margins of profit because you're in the
wholesale right so it's all about volume
and credibility if you can move that
much volume it really doesn't matter if
you profit or not it's just like
a hot product right credibility so i
think for us we had to strategically
make sure that we did well uh with our
amazon avenue
and at the end of the day it's like did
you guys have a planned road map like
that like kind of like first we're gonna
hit amazon then we gonna go get costco
totally and this leads to this this
leads to this and these are what's
hitting me walking it's always and it's
always like shopping the idea of
something around right it's it's always
like being like um nobody realistically
nobody knows how much we did in amazon
but it was important to like make sure
that we like sold out so we did sell out
amazon multiple times but at the end of
the day like real talk we didn't have a
lot of units we just bought five of them
and all five soldiers are buying your
own [ __ ] huh yeah filling warehouses
with the hell yeah
but like conversation i should have done
that i would have got a palette for you
guys that's what i'm saying pitch pitch
wise you're still gonna like talk to the
next person and be like hey uh amazon
sold out right now so if you want to
jump into this thing they don't go but
you only sold five of them but what if
the costco reps watching jk news right
now and they're like that's what he
[ __ ] did to him
you told me that kenji bane got into
costco i was like holy [ __ ] and i went
to costco and then i was like oh [ __ ]
they have non shim and i got some of
these
because it was cheaper really good i
mean like to be honest it tastes better
they had so much of it for so little
i'd rather go for that
that was cool but i meant to go for a
rep you did i meant to like at least
take a picture of it or something for
you
jabbawockeez right here just fyi
you're always number three or two on
everything
i'm just trying to be in the
conversation once
is it only at selected places though
like
can you go to any costco and get no not
yet not yet which costco it's in every
texas costco and there's a couple like
other midwest states like this a lot of
cowboys like instant noodles huh i love
that [ __ ] how many costcos are in texas
all i know is there's a few but all i
know is we're gonna we're in 41 stores
right damn
yeah is there any here in california not
yet how can you miss skipper california
dude of course we don't want to hate on
cali bro yeah dude you give it to the
cowboys before you give it to the
californians kenji noodles to to
california drop dead yeah yeah dude
how did that work out how did texas
become the first place before yeah
how did how did texans
they just they just do their demo
research stuff like that uh uh honestly
there's a [ __ ] ton of asians in texas in
the midwest oh it's their callers
way more [ __ ] asians here it's
costco's call you [ __ ] costco you son
of a [ __ ] hawaii has the most asians
yeah you know what i can't say though
yeah uh officially now we are also in
every 7-eleven in hawaii oh
[ __ ] that's crazy why do you see me at
7-eleven out there but they're not the
costco out there 7-elevens called bro
i've been trying to buy a kenji bang
noodles for so long i can't get them
anywhere just go to texas yeah okay yeah
[ __ ] yeah i'm gonna go back to hawaii
and if i don't see kenji bangs
chinga bangs chicken banks
dude can they buy it online like let's
say someone's watching jingle bangs dude
if someone wants to buy it on reaper
you can still buy it on amazon you can
also buy on kinderbangnoodles.com
but it's just the way to like get into
certain you know distribution and stuff
like that like
it's a it's
it's a game what's the best way to
support you like let's say people are
watching and they want to support you is
it better for your numbers if it's on
amazon or better for your numbers on
school where do we go to buy it a best
case scenario we all got to go to texas
yeah it's it's like make sure that we
hit specific numbers like we're you know
um
i'm not talking about the numbers that
we're doing but like ultimately like
it's always what does it rhyme with
though
what number does it ride with a drillian
bang
or bevan killian
what does it rhyme with
by bundred bowsend
something like that
dude holy [ __ ] i actually went to
711.com and they have nonship wow
that's great i didn't know that you're a
piece of [ __ ]
everything about you and now they have
spicy i don't know why i thought you're
gonna pull around the [ __ ] kindred
[ __ ] i didn't know why i thought you was
at home i'm telling you this stuff is
spicy dude stop laughing rick stop it
damn it
[ __ ] dude i'm gonna go to 7-eleven if
they don't have it i'm gonna get mad
is it there now it's 7-eleven and why
not hawaii yeah you guys go in hawaii
and texas
go get kenzie bangs right now
don't get non-ship don't care dude
oh [ __ ] play it out bro and it's you
gotta get kendra thanks gingerbang is
dry noodles let me be clear go go for
gingerbread but then yeah if you see
nonship
he's like i gotta go support the hobie
and then you're like oh you gotta bounce
up
and it's cheaper these are good noodles
i'm telling you man they're [ __ ]
spicy so
you're a piece of [ __ ] too for that one
oh i got i got a branding slash business
question for you
do you see
relating to this do you see nam shim as
a competitor or do you see other dance
crews as competitors nonsense commander
so you oh so you're really trying to get
the noodle space that's a big competitor
for you i bet
i know why why and why do you see them
as a competitor more than like another
dance crew i don't know broadening the
horizons
well i mean the second that you we took
even a step into cpg right like consumer
package goods this is the second you we
walked into a multi-billion billion
trillion dollar industry yeah
billion by 100
you know what i'm saying whereas like
even in the dance space it's like
um
they're we're
we're in such a small
like you know like dance is big around
the world but at the end of the day it's
such a small bubble of like what it
actually is as an industry you know what
i'm saying literally like dollars
generated this week the whole nike theme
that came out you know like that's like
the most progressive another win oh yeah
yeah you know nike shouted you guys out
more than shouted baby come on we they
just posted um we we finally get to uh
announce that we've been working for the
last four years on uh consulting with
tinker hatfield to define uh design the
first ever dance shoe that's true wow
tinker hatfield is a legendary designer
to design all the jordans by the way are
they gonna be is it gonna be called the
ninja shoe yeah no it's it no it's
called the air sesh air session but it's
a dance shoe yeah it's a dance that's a
joke we've literally been consulting for
four years on the same on this major
idea haven't been able to talk about it
and this week they just dropped that you
know so uh so you could talk about it
and finally get to talk about it now was
the first thing you did email
jabberwockies and be like dude you gotta
shoot me
[Laughter]
do you have the jab walking like on
their phone number let's call them up
dude let's do it come on jabba numbers
do you actually have
maybe like maybe like three or four or
five call them up wow that's like i want
them in a group text so you can [ __ ]
throw the [ __ ] off
just in case anybody's like chopping off
for the first time i do not hate the
jablock i don't know dude [ __ ]
right here are talking [ __ ] all day but
we are trying to take nonship down i'll
say that out loud hey way to be careful
boy be careful
i'd be scared of knock [ __ ] more than
jabba walkies yeah dude
i'm not scared i'm inspired by jab
hockey today's video is brought to you
by
tushy
okay man
you know when we went to japan and we we
we everywhere we went the mall the
public park the train stations
everywhere had a bidet yep i was kind of
jealous but it inspired us to get a
bidet for everywhere that we are we're
at like the office yeah our bedroom our
house i mean the closet everywhere
everywhere i would i would sleep with a
bidet under me if i could because it
keeps my butt warm it does yeah and but
days are freaking awesome if you've
never used one before it is a straight
up shower for your butthole and it feels
super fresh sometimes even you wipe
and you use like a wet wipe or whatever
at the end of the day you still
feel
insecure about yourself
but with a bidet especially like tushy
where it's so easy to install it sprays
your butthole nice and clean so it feels
fresh all the way until the end of the
day let me ask you guys something
when you
poop on your sleeve right let's say you
wipe right
and then when you want to sleep just say
like you're wiping your butt but then
you get it on your [ __ ] sleeve right
damn that sucks do you
just get a paper towel and without any
water do you just wipe that off no you
don't use you get water you get soap you
get all kind of stuff and you try to get
it off your sleeve yes right yeah and
you try to soak it and wash it
so why would you just scrape your butt
with dry paper yeah you're just smearing
[ __ ] all over that booty hole yeah
doesn't make any sense and the underwear
is probably screaming
and this is why it is just the more
civilized decision to get yourself a
bidet yes so make sure you go to tushy
go to hellotushi.com
off the record to get 10 off i highly
recommend it because you're gonna have
the cleanest butthole ever and it's free
shipping and it's only for our listeners
only it's a special deal go to
hellotushy.com off the record to get 10
off after you buy and install your two
sheets don't forget to tag us and act
hello tushy so we can all see your new
bathroom setup
how do you take out a giant like that
what's your guy's strength naksham is
like north korea how are you gonna do
that if everything's like north korea
dude they're huge how are you gonna do
it though like is there a strategy to do
that
um i think first and foremost uh we are
small as [ __ ] compared to them i think
it's okay to admit that yeah you guys
don't have one pal that i saw the
picture i got invited to go to their
factory well i was dog [ __ ] i suppose i
need it because people like me are going
for the kitchen and we're scooping up
the [ __ ] option
i got i got invited to do a long [ __ ]
this is the weirdest [ __ ] hat ever
i'm not even gonna show this to my
partners for damn sure like oh did you
guys talk about noodles on jk
it's really all good
do you guys like mata tron though oh my
god yeah
let's talk about all the other instant
noodles we like pork one dude i get it
every time what section isn't it is it
in the instant noodles yeah it's in the
noodles you don't go wear a dancer put
us next to the boom boxes
i think honestly on on a serious on a
serious uh uh kind of note to like what
you were even asking about like i
wouldn't want kendra's to only be like
understood or perceived as dancers
especially as we jump into a much larger
space or industry right like when
somebody looks like kindergarten news i
don't give a [ __ ] if they see kenja's as
a dance crew at all
i really don't care i'd rather than just
be like do you like the noodles yeah you
don't understand because that's a whole
different conversation that's like apple
do you like the laptop yeah or do you
like the watch [ __ ] um
i like the laptop yeah yeah right and
and honestly even that's actually a
really good example even with apple it's
like remember when uh apple was always
about computers but it's like they're
they're
before it was a phone oh why would you
do a thumbnail before it was a phone is
just a music player that was actually
the biggest thing that they had ever
created and they changed the music world
more than they changed the computer
world so it's kind of like
if i were to be ambitious and hopeful
same thing like
kendra's is like um
i hope that we're like more like the
rock one day you know that wrestling is
part of his dna but today the world
doesn't need to see him wrestle or
anything like that but you know that
like that's where it came from and i
would love for kendra to always be of
course we all we always will have dance
in our game from dance yeah but like my
ass is getting old and i don't want to
dance all the time either and i would
way rather sit back [ __ ] people not buy
a nunchuck and buy [ __ ] noodles you
know so kids your bang is better
do your joints hurt because you're old
recovery is way harder for sure damn for
sure it's way harder nowadays that's
crazy
but the shoes
go help the shoes do help the shoes do
help thank you very much more
comfortable than adidas or no
those are real comfortable
what was the best dance shoot until you
guys coming in and taking that over see
to be completely honest dances are so
[ __ ] fickle because it's always about
style over comfort right with the right
side with the right song i got to dance
with timbaland's on it's like that's not
a [ __ ] comfortable dance shoe but it
looks hard as [ __ ] right or if i want to
be like you know doing like memphis
joking or like you know glides and [ __ ]
i'll throw on some jordans but it's not
like flexible enough for me to like move
quickly to like a housebeat so it's like
we didn't have the right thing we're
always kind of jumping in basketball
shoes running shoes depending on the
style what about kung fu shoes they're
really light yeah yeah yeah but they
might not necessarily have the grip of
the spin you know what i mean in order
to give you a different type yeah you
could spin like crazy on this just an
example of like a current dance shoe
oh
those are nice those are ugly dude
dancers like to pick out that's tight
this is all different that looks like a
real dance crew yeah that looks like air
like air max or some [ __ ] i don't really
like their branding i don't really like
their shoes i like them anymore not a
fan really yeah i like them
they remind me of like this one dance
crew back in the day that won first
place on this show called america's best
dance crew this is quest crew they look
like if they made noodles
easily they win they're fueled by monks
bro if java ever came out and said
sponsored by nancy i will [ __ ] kill
myself
you win all right i [ __ ] would just
exit the game
to [ __ ] my life
and they have an adidas shoe called the
jabba and it's a [ __ ] dance show i
will [ __ ] suck all their dicks and
just [ __ ] quick they're gonna have a
[ __ ] talk show like this
that's bigger that's bigger and better
joe rogan they got a student called
jabba dojo
damn that would be crazy java news
japanese jb news dude did you guys watch
the japanese they're in every sam's club
jabba news hell yeah there we go there
you go the rules are better yeah i like
how your [ __ ] looks like an nft man oh
[ __ ] very good macros too i believe he's
actually showing our noodles finally
i mean for the best for
right now we got one but we're like
super excited at the early next year
well i don't know if i'm gonna say it
but [ __ ] i'm gonna say it you only have
a spicy one you only have a spicy one
right so it's called the spicy one right
now but actually one we're actually
we're actually uh going to take spicy
off of that one yeah because we like
barely change it by small percentage so
we legally can don't have to call it
spicy anymore yeah but we're making
another spicier one and this bomb is
[ __ ] with different
with different noodle cut sizes
like thin and [ __ ] or like thick and
[ __ ] can you make a soup one
please all right cool thanks
[Laughter]
get that we'll get it very good that's
awesome but yeah that whole process what
is the new flavors coming
hopefully uh topping next year
wow
next year and then are you gonna
incorporate nike into your noodles no
damn yeah that'd be sick though huh you
have a [ __ ] bowl of noodle in the
shape of a shoe and then you it's like a
cup of noodle but a shoe a noodle and
then you pull it over you pull it open
and you just pour water in it and then
you're not writing this down you should
be writing it would be lit yeah i do i
will say that we did we were inspired to
make our noodle box uh like a sneaker
box that's why it looks the way it does
oh that's cool yeah you guys really have
good designing man
it's tight it's a good brand very good
the noodles are very good it tastes good
because usually like things that look
cool they don't taste good i like the
texture of it but it actually tastes
really it's really good like if you if
you know you get your into your flow of
how long to like heat the water or
whatever and it gets like more al dente
yeah yeah super bomb you throw all your
leftovers on it and [ __ ] it's super bomb
because last time i ate it i was like
damn i feel so healthy i got to get a
nom shing now to so if
not like a regular noodle it's like too
healthy yeah dude
okay wait wait wait wait wait wait damn
it
it was going so good
didn't you tell me that um it's
technically not an instant noodle
because of the way it's made yeah it's
it's legally not called an instant
noodle because it's air dried it's never
fried yeah because instant noodle you
literally it's already cooked right so
you could remember as a kid you could
break those noodles just eat them up
yeah but with this one you can't eat it
raw because it's considered raw it's air
dried it's an actual you know noodles
you gotta boil that [ __ ] yeah you got
it it has a nice texture yeah so it
tastes so fresh it's red never fried see
and it's plant-based but obviously
noodles are all plant-based but it's
usually in the sauce that they always
put in things that are like meat-based
oh it's so good in our sauce we made a
vegan friendly which is why i'm gonna
compete with you guys and be like you
got a carrot in it
in the vegetable packet we do it's the
best vegan food i've ever had yeah jam
bro i'm a compete i'm gonna be i'm gonna
be like the most unhealthiest [ __ ]
noodle on planet earth it's my second
favorite too
[ __ ] watch out i'm gonna be making
non [ __ ] yeah
there you go non [ __ ] because i don't
take that somebody hold him back
give me double fried fried animal fat
yup would you man [ __ ] that we'll get
animal fat from endangered species yeah
like what kind what kind rhino rhino
white rhino yeah the last one
and it it'll be only 20 cents yep right
now it's cheap it's unhealthy it tastes
really good bad for the environment bad
for the environment let's go
where are we saying about the process
that it's really hard
uh just like the the way to like
manufacture and then like shipping
getting things over and then like
purchase orders from different like
places right and like especially once
you go into like larger distribution
like the quantity that they order you're
like it feels like [ __ ] forever 21 is
like coming to your mom and pop like
seamstress like i just designed some
fast fashion and they're like all right
now we do a bulk order and if you don't
sell this well by the way you're like
[ __ ] yeah how do you how many uh
what's the bulk order for 41 costcos bro
it's a lot like to see like the shipping
container like have like all the pallets
and stuff like that do you have a
picture of that i might have a video how
many containers oh dude just like to see
even a whole truck full of like eight
pallets you're like i've never seen this
in my life you know what i'm saying you
never worked in the warehouse because
you never did man's work full get the
[ __ ] out
yeah [ __ ] dude i was unloading trucks
as a 120 pound man
yeah dude you're disgusting i thought
you were just [ __ ] i just bought some
kimchi bang right now dude on amazon did
you no he told you go to costco i can't
i can't go to texas i gotta i gotta get
it on amazon
you get to add the option it's going to
be here tomorrow and i got some options
it comes together
i would like to really quickly read a
review of kinder bang noodles from
amazon.com uh-oh hell yeah this person
says i was cautiously cautiously
optimistic about these noodles wow
so they looked at the noodles and like i
don't know about this [ __ ]
what's cautiously optimistic
i don't know about this [ __ ]
the inflection
i've eaten ramen noodles maro chan for
most of my childhood and well into my
adult life i love asian noodles whoa i
also love the dance scene and i was kind
of scratching my head when the kinjas
announced they were coming out with
noodles but being a fan of the dance
group and the food group i was quick to
order these as soon as they they popped
up verdict they're good but they're a
bit spicy for people like my wife who
don't like spicy foods well [ __ ] her
then [ __ ] your little [ __ ]
why is she eating a noodle that says
spicy she doesn't like spices yeah you
don't like spicy [ __ ]
capital c
capital c go figure it out
it's like oh i hate spicy let me bite
into a jalapeno yeah i don't like this
[ __ ]
yeah so does everybody else nobody likes
her it looks cool it's so wet sorry
continue so then he says um yeah my wife
doesn't like spicy foods but she's a
[ __ ] anyway yeah
but for me it was the perfect amount of
spice i'm hoping they come out with
different flavors in the future it's a
little awesome i like this guy's good
man
and the consistencies of the noodles is
perfect
my only minor complaint is that i wanted
more oh
it's a
it's a good serving size
but i gotta tell myself not to make two
packs for myself it's no non-shim
amazon oh go support our very own
anthony
it's right here kendrick
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]